[Music]
[Applause]
what is up guys in today's video I'm
going to be flipping sets specifically
armor sets page set those kind of sets
and I'm gonna be trying to make a lot of
money but we're going to see how much
money I can make in one hour I'm going
to be using seven mil to start with so
let's go ahead and go to the grand
exchange and start the timer so the
first item I'm going to be doing is my
favorite set to flip it's art doesn't
armor right now they're going for about
100k profit if you can buy all the
pieces and then sell them as a set for
the proper price so I just use OS buddy
because it tells me the prices they are
selling for and they're almost always
accurate
so for 14 let's just try that if 90 so
quickly then I will just go ahead and up
the prices
you
so other sets that I like to use are the
guthix D hide so I'm going to add up all
this on my phone and then I will be back
and see if these make profits so another
set that I found that it works for
profit is the taurog set so we're going
to go ahead and try that I did the math
for the ethics D hide one and it was not
going to make profit so well the target
L sold right away let's hope all these
other items so right away - nope just
the home and as you can see the Dustin's
plate skirt sold already I'll show you
guys the time after this just so you
guys can see that I'm not cheating or
anything
oops
oops alright
so
you
so these two items already sold - but
time is at 3:30 so I'm gonna go ahead
and let these sit and then when they buy
I will try to sell them so these already
sold so I'm going to go ahead and try to
up the Torx hammers and then if this
buys I'm going to go ahead and buy all
these again all right so that just means
that our camera is not something because
it would buy for 2:18 normally so I will
be back when these sell so while all
these are buying still I'm going to go
ahead and buy the Armadale pages because
right now it's about a 80k profit if you
put it together and sell book so we'll
go ahead and put this in for 195 K these
pages normally take a while to buy so I
will not be surprised with these don't
buy so if they don't buy at all then I'm
just going to go ahead and move on to
another thing because I don't want to
waste any time because we only have an
hour and we are at almost 10 minutes so
I will just keep putting in an offer for
these
buying what see so we bought two
pages so let's hope these other two
pages by if they don't by soon then I
want up the price and same with the guns
war speed towards hammer and the guns
play buddy
so the torques hammer bought so I will
go ahead and make this set and then sell
that for I figure what the profit was
but
good so 8:30
so while these are selling and buying I
will go ahead and look at the profit
until you guys because I forget what I
said the Prophet was and I'm kind of
curious so this charge that sells it
will be about a 40k profit so let's hope
it sells so all these pages sold so how
much is the book of law I think it's the
book of law book of law
hopefully I put the set together first
so I think this is like 100k profit if
I'm not wrong I'm not right so let's go
ahead and sell that and see how much it
sells for that was instant I'm not sure
what the profit was but I'm pretty sure
that was like 100k so I might try to do
that again let's just go ahead and see
if we can do it again already bought
some of the page
hope this works looks like someone
selling them right now come on buy these
other two all right I didn't buy them
but we shall wait and yeah I made
hundred k profit so I'll be back so I'm
going with the prices for the plate body
and for the armor page one and for the
war spear the plate body sold with the
word spear is not sold and this page is
not sold we're almost about half way
we're hit in about 25 minutes so we need
some stuff to start selling if we want
to start making some money there is room
for 4 items so I'm going to look around
on some other sets and see how much
money I can make if I make set so I will
be back and hopefully something that's
old by the time I come back so
apparently if I buy the armadillo dragon
hide set I will make about I don't know
I think it was like 60 K or something I
just looked so let's go ahead and try
this hopefully I can get it these sets
are a little harder sometimes actually
nevermind I've never done the armadillo
dragon set that's what I'm trying to say
I normally just do the gut fix ones or
the stare Delmon or the bigger named
ones so far it looks like everything's
selling really well so let's hope I'll
just buy that for 60 cakes assignment so
people sell more anyways now these are
expensive I don't know why all right so
this is looking good this is looking
very very good now hopefully we can sell
the set for the right price and then we
will make like I said I think is 2 DK so
I will be back and hopefully some of
these items are sold by the time I'm
back so it hasn't even been that long
but it's getting a little frustrating
watching these ends not buy so I'm going
to go ahead and try to up this price on
here let's try one
one four one five five eight Kane let's
hope that doesn't leave that into a
little bit and this armored cage is not
buying which is really weird because I'm
buying it for quite a bit over maybe if
I put the put it in four more
I mean I'm really over buying this by
quite a bit I'm surprised it's not sign
since nine four one ninety two the
margins are really high right now so
we'll go ahead and put it in for 2:15
okay there we go that's all we needed
okay and now we'll go to the stats
and this one signed for a lot of profit
see one seven nine nine nine one seven
five zero okay let's try one seven eight
zero curious
yeah that's alright what did we sell for
last time I don't know why the margins
I've done so much that's weird because I
just sold this thing for one 718 and
that was a lot of profit so let's try
one 718 again instant sold one 725 so
I'm just making more money on these so I
will just go ahead and buy these for
more so 1 2 sound advice on my put that
in for more 3
or is it for
so I will go ahead and try to put these
in four more and see if I can find it
quicker so we'll die by about the one in
the three so I need the four and the two
hope I don't buy the wrong one the next
I'll do that
so I need the - I mean it's making a lot
of profits I may as well put the price
way up okay it's about and I need the
four
you
okay this is very good
okay so the four
so far
one seven two five so we'll try one
seven two zero
okay we'll leave that one in and
hopefully these items sell and buy by
the time I am back I will be back where
you're sitting at 37 minutes so we're
over halfway there
so if we can sell these items I think
we're going to be quite a bit ahead so
let's hope these sell so unfortunately I
just realized the taurog armor set has
dropped a lot it's now something for
heat or nine so I moved it down to a 25
hopefully that'll work because I don't
want to have to go ahead and instant
sell it and I move down the armadillo
dragonhide site because I'm at 41
minutes so I really wanted to sell and
this book of law isn't selling is is
really interesting because it was signed
for quite a bit before let's try 1 7 15
all right yeah so 1 7 18 again okay
let's see if I can instant buy these in
I just need to page 3 right 1 2 for
sodium 2 3
try to 531 so I'm not sure what the
profit is on these but I know it's a lot
so after I sell this one I will go ahead
and figure out how much I'm making
because I hope I'm making what I think
of me because I think I'm making a lot
okay one sec I will do the math and I
will be right back yes I'm making 50k on
each of these so I'm going to try to do
it again
I ensure what the pilot is on these and
if there's a buy limit
I mean 50k each time this
I mean we stupid not to keep doing this
first buying these I'm happy
oh damn oh so it's 50k so let's see if
we can sell it for
7:10
okay we'll leave it in at that for a
little bit because whoever was buying
them for 117 clearly stopped making them
and that's still about a 40k profit so
I'll go ahead and leave all these items
I'm at 42 minutes so I don't know why
this Kevin's worst fear has not bought
this stores armor set I'm probably
enough to sell for super cheap this
armadillo dragon set I just need someone
to buy it and let's hope everything
sells so 43 minutes so I have about just
under 20 minutes left so I will be right
back when these sell thankfully as I was
doing the math is towards armor set sold
so I didn't lose as much money as I
thought I was going to lose only lost
about 10k so hopefully I can figure out
this Geffen's fiasco and then sell this
and then we'll see how much money I made
so when head and putting these guns
offers and I think I'm breaking even on
them so I'm going to go ahead and sell
this was the time at 51 so I'm really
coming down to crunch time here so I'm
going to go ahead and try to sell this
Forge for 20k
okay so that's all so now it is
this item I will give it until 60
minutes and then I will just sell it
instantly because I don't think it's
going to sell actually I might try to
buy one more page set or make some last
minute money
look like they're buying yeah someone
must have changed the margin or figure
this out and none of them are buying so
can't do that I'm a little disappointed
to Gustin set in flip because I would
have been about 50k right there but I
couldn't do that
so maybe I can figure out a last-minute
flip I'll look real quick I have about
seven minutes left let's hope this thing
sells and I will be back so it doesn't
look like this is gonna sell I'm at 58
minutes I'm just going to go ahead and
sell it let's let's pray that it sells
for at least 500 cakes I really don't
always not much money on it are you
serious this thing was supposed to make
me like 50k profit I don't know what the
hell's going on
it's not even zoned for that why is no
one buying this set come on that's why
you got to stick away from these sets
guys use the name-brand stuff what use
the name-brand ones like the gothic sets
and the saradomin ones okay it's old so
I made 258 K in one hour that's not
terrible but it's definitely not what I
wanted to make but I just made this
video to show you guys that you can just
flip sets really easily to make money
and I've been wanting to make more
flipping videos because they're really
fun to make because I do flip a lot I
have made a lot more money than this in
an hour but I didn't get as many flips
as I wanted to the guthix the gustin's
ones weren't flipping I couldn't get any
of the beehives input but anyway thanks
guys for watching and stay tuned for the
next video
[Music]